good morning thank you for joining us on
the program um labor want liz trust to
win why is that from the conversations
i've had with labour peers and one or
two labour mps
the frank conversations they're not
trying to kind of
maneuver a double bluff or something
they see rishi's weaknesses as his tax
position and his wealth
but he is a success story
and they believe that will probably go
down well in places like leicester and
bradford
whereas liz truss has not subjected
herself to
a full cross-examination um by any of
the major programmes and didn't perform
well in the debates
and therefore they feel that in at the
dispatch box
that she will be easier as a target
and easier to to take down
do you have to be a good debater to be a
good prime minister
you need that skill because we have this
very brutal process in our parliament of
prime minister's question time every
wednesday
and although
the vast majority of the population
doesn't watch it it's that that
percolates through the party members
through the associations and therefore
people will be judging it in terms of
who's going to win my marginal seat
how surprised were you by the result
yesterday
not really
i'm more surprised by the earlier rounds
where the ebbs and flows are voting
whether there was a bit of conspiracy
and maneuvering i'm not really sure
because there was
of course there was you know i'm not you
know i'm fairly cynical about
politicians yeah so yeah they're they're
not there's nothing wrong with it
absolutely perfectly entitled to do that
happens in other organizations and
businesses as well uh but the actual
outcome once we've got to the final
round uh a marginal liz trust victory
over penny morton uh was likely
i think just the way the voters that the
people who were um then available in
terms of uh casting their votes who
previously voted for other candidates
were likely just slightly uh more
heavily to go for liz truss so penny
modern um i mean it was always the
bookies favorite they were they were you
don't you really see a poor bucky do you
so what happened there i think the
answer is
and it's one of the reasons one has to
be cautious about looking at any opinion
poll of members is because actually the
support has ebbed and flowed quite
markedly in the last two or three weeks
between one candidate and another and of
course one of the key things that both
candidates will now be looking to
is to get the support of penny mordant
and her supporters out in the country
because support from penny could well be
key when it comes to votes in
constituencies interesting i was at the
30 last uh yesterday actually just to
kill a mockingbird if you haven't seen
it you should go it's amazing happily um
and uh there was a chap during the
interval saying is penny morgens going
to win because i've got 20 quid on her
at 25 to 1. um so she's still very much
you know there or there about on
people's minds very much so isn't she
will she be the king maker
she could influence the result there's
absolutely no question that and by the
way my brother's also had money on penny
morton so
he's done it as well then yeah
but no uh she could well have a major
influence and mps themselves will
influence their constituency
associations because members who don't
know liz trust or issue that well will
turn to their mp where they have a
conservative mp and say who do you
support why did you support them will it
benefit me as a council candidate at the
next local elections these are the sorts
of questions and conversations that will
be taking place over the next few weeks
who do you think she'll fall in behind i
don't know i spoke to her briefly
yesterday but that was she before she
was fine but that was before the result
so i haven't spoken to her since
but
she may keep her own council she may go
public uh kemi begnock and michael gove
two other very influential people have
not said anything at this stage um they
are also the sorts of people who will
influence conservative members how nasty
is this going to get
it's not nice um you look at primaries
in the united states you look at what
happens in france in terms of leadership
contests uh it's it's not nice
but what actually happens in the long
run is that particularly because we're
likely to have one and a half to two
years till the next general election
um the
kiss and makeup might be a slight
exaggeration but there's no question
that
issues will become policy issues will
become far more important than what was
said in in midnight mid 2022.
talk to me about uh how the next six
weeks play out because um in the movie
industry they call it hitches so there
are certain hitches as you go along what
are we watching out for well
clearly the two debates for the reason
that i identified at the start uh
liz trust didn't do well in either of
the two debates particularly paulie in
the first one so for her
those two appearances
and any individual cross-examinations
at length that she
makes on any uh program will be key for
her and
they're important for rishi as well one
shouldn't underestimate that and uh you
and pollsters and everybody always
saying this is how they performed
that's the key thing but also
there will be the meetings of party
members
which people are being notified of and
again particularly the early ones if i
was managing either of the campaigns and
i'm sure they're taking that view
they've got to get everything front
loaded because
many people having received their ballot
will actually just return it asap
so you need to get the the blow the
comments in very early so you don't
stick it on the fridge and sort of wait
for six weeks to see how it's gonna
happen some people might do and then
forget about it
some people forget their lottery tickets
so uh uh but yes so i think the majority
will be returned fairly quickly and
they're open the ballots open from the
fifth of august the day after our debate
from the fifth of august
and the result will be declared on the
fifth of september okay um what about
hustings how does she do in hustings
list
well
we'll find out how well she did but say
there is a sense that the first of
particularly the first of the two
debates she didn't do well in and the
hustings are going to be fairly similar
um in terms of process
for party members and therefore um those
will matter because even people who are
not able to to get in or watch them
virtually um they will have friends who
go or watch and and they will
communicate with each other and the big
issues you think are inflation cost of
living and and it's we still hear about
brexit and i know that rishi tsunak was
having a pop-up this trust about her
being a former remainer does it matter
anymore are we all brexiteers now i
think and i've made this observation i
think on this program previously that
the level of factionalism rebrexit has
diminished from previous leadership
elections
you can say obviously the obvious ones
are things like the economy and taxation
but i think it's likely that there will
be surprise issues
you covered
as did everybody the fires yesterday
funding of the fire service funding of
the health service if there is a
particular crisis in some form or
another will suddenly become center
stage
and therefore the next few weeks are
going to be highly unpredictable because
it will be responsive to what are the
major news stories of that particular
week and do you think green levees and
climate change has its place i spoke to
one mp who said because there was
pressure why don't we just vote every
day two or three times a day till we get
down to two candidates and one mp said i
don't know what the candidate's views
are on environment matters so there were
a number of mps who were advocating that
they should have which they did have
internal hustings to cover the issues
which are important to large sections of
the population
um what what are the polls telling you
internal polls telling you as far as
these two candidates are concerned at
the moment there's no question liz truss
is in the lead um you have
a respected and long-term pollster but
even those polls from the different
companies have fluctuated quite
dramatically as you said penny was
favored um only a few days ago to win so
the polls the betting fluctuating a lot
so that says there is a lot of people
out there who actually haven't decided
they haven't got firm views one way or
the other and how interesting is it how
concerning should it be for the
conservative party for the government
that they seem to have such a disconnect
between the mps and what the grassroots
think
um i'm not sure whether there is that
disconnect i think there is a
fluctuation the mps were desperate to
get rishi soon act through whereas it
seems grass roots are not at all well
we've got one poll on one day but you
there are other polls that have shown
fluctuations over the last two or three
weeks so as i said just now don't take
one poll as a clear indication of where
they've been set previous elections
leadership elections have been very much
more more clear
it's been set on a certain course and
that's where it's gone to
um it went out to the members between
boris and jeremy but we we we knew that
boris was going to win that's not so
clear this time and therefore there will
be
say the hitch points uh during the next
few weeks on issues that have been
unexpected
and candidates stumble but they don't
often fall no who's going to win my lord
uh i'm waiting to see
i genuinely don't know because of this
fluctuation in the opinion polls
and the messages that i'm hearing there
are let's say there's a lot of people
who don't know
uh in the membership
and there have been varying views and
then say those who are supporting penny
morton a large block of the party both
within
mps and outside have they've got to
decide and and that's why debates are so
important they are okay it's great to
see him thank you as always thank you